nuevos aires políticos en américa
latina' el presidente de chile gabriel
boric recibió a la vicepresidenta electa
de colombia francia márquez en el
palacio de la moneda
esto cuando falta poco más de una semana
para que se vuelvan a encontrar en la
posesión presidencial de colombia
hoy tuvo el honor de recibir a la futura
vicepresidenta de colombia francia
márquez gran lideresa y defensora
medioambiental con quien comparto la
visión de unión de nuestros pueblos y
américa latina' miró con mucha esperanza
y alegría lo que está pasando en
colombia tras la cita a francia market
participó en un encuentro feminista anti
racista en la universidad de chile en
santiago
ocasión que aprovechó para hacer un
anuncio resultado del encuentro con
gabriel boric saludamos con mucha
alegría que hoy el presidente boris haya
manifestado no sólo su disposición de
acompañarnos en esta tarea del logro de
la paz
sino que ofrece su casa chile como sede
para los diálogos de paz entre el estado
colombiano y el l
antes de esta semana francia market se
había reunido con el candidato y ex
presidente brasileño luis ignacio lula
da silva este viernes se verá con el
presidente de argentina alberto
fernández antes de terminar su gira en
bolivia con un encuentro con el que será
su homólogo david choquehuanca
encuentros en los que sumar apoyos en la
paz total que persigue el gobierno de
gustavo petro tras el precedente acuerdo
de paz de 2016 con las farc ahora es el
turno de ln después de unas
conversaciones que se iniciaron durante
el gobierno de juan manuel santos en
2017 en quitó se trasladaron en 2018 a
la habana y quedaron suspendidas durante
el gobierno de iván duque en 2019